the good doctor is quickly becoming one
of my favorite medical dramas and you
continually requested so I figured let's
just go ahead and watch the second
episode of the first season it does not
look like a comfortable sleeping
position I wish I was this happy when I
woke up early in the morning what is he
measuring for to San Jose Saint
Bonaventure Hospital I'm a surgical
resident today is my first full day on
that floor I like this show I don't know
I gets me happy it just puts me in a
good mood this is Mitchell brand I
reviewed his chart he's 55 years old
from Chicago divorced with two children
you did a radical prostatectomy on him
yesterday this is actually very accurate
in a post-op unit you will get visited
by the attending physician the head
physician who is usually the main
surgeon and they will have their
residents following them along here in
this case the patient had a radical
prostatectomy which is a removal of the
entire prostate gland I have a whole
video on the prostate and how things can
go wrong with it so if you want to check
that out on my channel the thing about
the radical prostatectomy why it's the
difficult surgeries because there's a
lot of nerves in the region of the
prostate
amongst other structures that are very
anatomically important including your
urinary system your semen duck going in
to perform that surgery you want to make
sure that anatomically you're very
careful not to damage the surrounding
structures but as we know things can go
wrong and things happen you're late five
minutes without that your first day no
less it is your responsibility to be
here if you are not you have failed in
your responsibilities which makes it
your fault okay how can it be my fault I
did nothing wrong the bus this is gonna
work out great the board clearly made
the right choice in hiring you thank you
I think the attending is being mean but
on the other hand I think he's right as
a doctor it's very important to be on
time there should be no excuses because
ideally you should be there early being
a good resident it's ideal to get places
early so that you can review the charts
beforehand get all the information so
that when you aren't rounding with your
attending you know all the information
it's definitely
and the left kidney renal Angela my
lipoma you see an expensive blood supply
god I wish I could do this - she has a
sarcoma a malignant tumor means it's
killing me right yes I get that it may
have features of a malignant sarcomas
but to know instantly without a proper
biopsy it could be several things -
that's it you just accept my answer at
face value what you're very arrogant
people don't think that alive how long
will this be seven minutes without any
complications it takes seven minutes to
do a discharge examination properly
doctor Dunsmuir has already cleared him
to go and we need the bed okay
protocol requires that the surgical
department also clears him why is a
patient that has an ear infection
admitted into the hospital and question
number two why is a patient that has an
ear infection being treated by a member
of the surgical team are you doing down
here
lady you for her to fart
she had surgery but I'm using the word
fart in front of the patient to be more
casual because the president of the
hospital so I'll say flatulence to you
well I appreciate that
why are you doing she had a deviated
septum repaired before we can release
her we have to be sure she isn't
suffering from post-operative Ilyas
post-operative Ilyas is when the muscles
of the intestines don't move correctly
and basically it's like a frozen
intestine meaning that the gut is not
moving the food at its remnants and the
stool further down and allowing it to
pass this can't happen sometimes one of
the first things you wait is for the
patient to pass gas and then in some
cases if you had something more
complicated like a an abdominal surgery
you wait for them to have a stool before
sending them home I think that was it
[Music]
you don't have to smell it I don't think
so I'll wait a little longer this is
important if it's not the procedure is
called a laparotomy
your heart sounds good I don't know what
she was listening to her heart for that
was definitely just an add-on for the
show but when we listen to the heart we
listen to multiple areas when you're
listening to one area you're listening
to one part of the heart then you move
the set the scope around and you're
getting the other part of the heart
which gives you more information and
then you move it to the other side of
the chest where you're listening to
separate arteries so you can hear what
they orders doing when you can hear what
the pulmonary valve is doing has been
tight in a car accident a couple of
years ago mark is our only child I can't
die right before his wedding I can't
you're not gonna be making promises like
that I've said it before it's not wise
we have only so much control over
certain things especially they don't
know the grade of this tumor they don't
know the spread of the tumor a little
girl has a tummy ache because mommy and
daddy won't stop fighting this isn't a
medical issue send them home could be
intestinal malrotation which could
quickly become fatal and every patient
in this hospital could have malaria that
doesn't mean we're gonna go around
testing for every condition we think
they could have or during random tests
just to make sure that a patient doesn't
have that condition is certainly not
smart and I agree with the senior
attending here what you learn from
experience is when you go on the hunt
and you start ordering a bunch of tests
certain tests will come up positive
mostly because a lot of those tests have
the high possibility of coming back as
false positives which then encourages
you to order more tests which has
several effects the patient gets anxiety
second some tests carry risks for
example if you start ordering cat scans
on every patient you're exposing the
patient's unnecessary radiation on top
of that you may find on a cat scan some
kind of nodules some kind of node which
will need further testing
sometimes a biopsy biopsies carry risks
you see where I'm going with this from
now on you don't run any tests you don't
have to work how do I know if a test is
needed until after I run it
she'll tell you nurses actually have a
lot of experience in knowing what tests
to run which tests are excessive which
tests are very important in fact when
the residents of my hospital ran rapid
responses the nurses from the ICU were
so experienced they already knew what
medications to pull off at what dosages
even more so than some of the young
residents I'm dr. Blair Brown I'm first
assist today and I'll be leaving the
timeout patients name Stephanie Willis
scheduled surgery excision of an
indeterminate retroperitoneal - oh now
it's anticipate any complications with
the surgery thank you dr. Brown that
timeout actually happens it's basically
we confirm all of the information
generally we do and while the patient's
awake so they can confirm all this
information and then we do it one more
time before we start including this may
surprise you
discussing the site of the operation
because it has happened unfortunately
horribly that we've operated on the
wrong side of a patient's body there's
been a lot of things put in place
procedures put in place that prevent us
from making that horrible mistake with
the timeout being one of the most
important ones it's not there is some
discoloration he's 82 years old
everything is discolored blood pressure
120 over 70 or a 60 she's own steady you
know what you guys should do you should
screenshot this little scene where she
says I opened the fashio and send it to
Gabby Hannah because she tweeted me not
so long ago saying that she can't
believe that after we operate on organs
that we put them back are they just like
floating around in our bodies and I told
her that everything is interconnected
with fashio and she had no idea what
fashion looks like so send her this
picture on her Twitter she's gonna love
it
I thought you want to see it
looks like beautiful no it's not the
regular color puke is a regular color it
has a bit of an unusual color we could
order some I'm sending you home
part of Medicine and a big part of
Medicine and something that I learned
and teach my students is that a big part
of what we do is reassure because people
worry and there's a lot of anxiety that
comes with people's bodies fluids are
coming out of random places fluids
change color we bleed body aches our
heads hurt our vision changes a coffee
curse upset stomach as soon as you go on
the internet you look at any one of
these websites you can fall down into a
wormhole thinking that your headache is
caused by a tumor like this Claire tell
me you got something nothing bigger than
the looked on the scans
hence why we don't diagnose people just
by looking at skin
the tumor is encasing her aorta meaning
it's fully surrounding it in golfing day
Horta which serves to be the main blood
supply to the bottom of the body dr.
meléndez sent you a biopsy when will the
results be ready when I get to it it's
very important they're all very
important let me see the other test
orders I'll tell you which ones the most
important and you can do them in that
order
I'll be honest and fair in complex
surgeries like this we not only have the
pathology lab on standby but you could
also even have a pathologist in the room
with a microscope ready to make the call
immediately especially when a patient is
under sedation you don't want to extend
the patient's time under sedation just
because the pathologist is busy with
other cases there is one possibility
if we believe the left kidney we might
be able to get a good enough huge
success we moved amass tell your healthy
kidney to get a better view that's
insane
the tricky part with this is that if
they're not successful she could die if
they're somewhat successful she could be
incredibly disabled and have horrible
disability from the surgery and her last
six weeks to live with this horrible
tumor are gonna be awful as opposed to
if they just suture her up now and then
she can enjoy her last few weeks of life
even if the surgery is a major success
does that mean that they were able to
get the entire tumor out and now she's
completely cured it could be spread all
across the peritoneum which is the
inside of the abdominal cavity to me
this sounds too risky and too much of a
like a cowboy move but then again I'm
not a surgeon nor a surgical oncologist
that's why I would ask someone who's
more of a sub specialist which I don't
think any of these people are am i
healthy probably you're a doctor you're
supposed to know no or not nobody knows
anything for sure anybody could drop
dead of a heart attack at any time who
is this guy
am I gonna have a heart attack first of
all don't do this in an open space like
this because if he starts yelling it's
not gonna look good for anybody I have
these conversations all the time
patients come in and they man to know
that they're healthy there's nothing
wrong with them you can't promise that
what I can do is answer a specific
question they have about their health
doctor my ear hurts why do you think
that is and I could say well I looked in
your ear and I found that you have an
ear infection let's treat it and see
what the outcome is
you give them reassurance that it's
likely to pass but you tell them if the
symptoms continue if the symptoms are to
worsen if new symptoms appear please
return so we can do a further evaluation
that's it the smaller bowel is twisted
around the superior mesenteric artery
Marty needs surgery immediately we need
to confirm with sir Melendez no dr.
Melendez is in surgery part of Martin's
bowel is dying and killing her with it
no you cannot make these calls on your
own
dr. Melendez was very clear
he was very clear it's past midnight
which means it's tomorrow which means
you're no longer my boss his this deal
our scheduler yes this is dr. Murphy
prepare know our surgery as feel good as
this is an intern cannot just book a no
our can schedule their own surgery no
one would ever allow this to happen
actually this could be grounds for
expulsion from a surgical program why
don't all surgeons look so frail in
these shows him McDreamy
I mean I get your operating all the time
I come on a little deadlift and
benchpress never hurt nobody
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
I like the minimalist look for an
apartment oh he got a mattress look at
that upgrade when I say this show has
good writing I'm not talking about the
actual speech in the words that the
characters say that's good but when I
say great writing it means they think
ahead for each situation to make it not
only light-hearted comical fun and
interesting but they show a way to
highlight a person who has autism in
such a unique light that is very
positive for people who are born or
develop this condition but this is
probably one of my favorite shows right
now as far as medical dramas go I'm
certainly a fan the reason I watched
episode 2 is because I want to learn
more about the first season before
jumping into the second season now if
there are some good episodes within the
first season you want me to watch please
let me know down below in the comments
hit that subscribe button and the
notification bell so you get all my
videos and check out my other content if
you enjoy my medical drama reviews
you'll love it or your money back
now so always stay happy and healthy
[Music]